au service de tous les canadiens quelle
que soit leur genre leur confession leur
langue leurs coutumes leur couleur de
peau
un rappel aux parlementaires qui longe
le retour au travail à la chambre des
communes
si chacun des trois cent trente huit
députés viennent y représenter un coin
et précis du pays
le libéral gwec fergus a l'impression
d'être un peu plus que la voix des
électeurs d olonne
c'est pas tout à fait juste de porter
mes épaules mais je reconnais que je
suis vingtaine de députés noirs
seulement cinq candidats noirs ont été
élus le 21 octobre
c'est un de moins que la dissolution du
parlement il représente à peine un an et
demi pour cent de tous les députés
les noix en forme pourtant trois et demi
pour sein de la population canadienne
s'il était représenté
proportionnellement 12 députés
siégeraient aux communes comme président
du caucus des noirs craig ferguson prend
une partie du blâme
c'est lui qui a la difficile tâche de
recruter de nouveaux candidats ils
comptent s'y prendre plus tôt que lors
des dernières élections
surtout qu'en contexte de gouvernement
minoritaire les prochaines élections
pourraient avoir lieu avant quatre ans
qu'ils aient déjà commencé le travail en
parlant avec des gens pour qui qui ont
un profil très intéressant à travers le
prix chez les autochtones la situation
stagne
ils sont toujours dix soit un peu moins
de 3 % de tous les députés
alors que les autochtones représente 4,9
pour cent de l'ensemble de la population
canadienne
j'ai été la présidente de la cre au
colloque tonne l'ancien député robert
falcon wallet reconnaît que les membres
des premières nations ont toujours eu de
la difficulté à s'identifier au système
politique canadien
eux qui n'ont obtenu le droit de vote
qu'en 1960 ils ont une grande réticence
envers les institutions keynésiens et de
confiance n'est pas là
l'effort devrait donc venir des partis
politiques surtout chez les libéraux et
conservateurs note cet expert les partis
qui ont le moins de chances de remporter
beaucoup de sièges font plus d'efforts
pour avoir une représentation qui soit
plus juste par exemple les
néo-démocrates en eau fait beaucoup de
travail alain terne recruter des
candidats n'est pas tout encore faut-il
qu'ils aient des chances réelles de
l'emporter d'avoir accès et les sièges
plus en sécurité
comme on appelle en anglais 17 sites eu
les sièges déjà gagné à l'avant malgré
la controverse des blagues fesses de
justin trudeau ou et fergus ne crois pas
que ces erreurs viennent décourager de
futurs candidats noirs
oui parce que on réalise de plus en plus
les décisions se comptent par des
personnes qui sont que les absents ont
toujours tort si la diversité en
politique est un objectif noble françois
rocher crois qu'une meilleure
représentation de l'ensemble de la
population canadienne a des impacts bien
réelle des sensibilités qui autrement
seraient pas exprimée dans le caucus ou
dans les comités au moment de
l'évaluation puis l'analyse des projets
de loi c'est donc dire que les cinq
députés noirs et dix députés autochtone
devront toujours redoubler d'ardeur en
entrant aux communes
ils savent qu'ils portent d espoir et d
inspiration qui dépasse les frontières
de leur circonscription
ici mathieu gaye et radio canada ottawa